[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
we have a live studio audience today
we're going to talk about why in a
moment but first let's talk about you
what negative outdated stories do you
tell yourself about who you are how do
those stories block your happiness peace
and freedom today on the podcast we're
joined by our good friend ian morgan
kron he's the author of this new book
i'll hold it up for youtube here it's
called the story
of
you
together we're going to rethink we're
going to help you rethink the stale
stories you tell yourself so that you
can let go of your past or even your
present identity we're talking about
identity clutter today then this
thursday on the minimalist private
podcast ryan ian and i
are going to examine your inner
strengths and weaknesses we'll also
discuss the nine personality types of
the enneagram there might be a reason we
have nine people in the studio today
nine different people
one might say we have the most diverse
team in podcasting the entire the
panoply the the complete bouquet of
human humanity is in the room that's
right you can check that out this
thursday patreon.com the minimalist your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me
advertisements suck
ian thank you so much for being here
today it is awesome to be in los angeles
great to have you man you're like one of
my favorite guests uh how many this is
our third podcast we've done together
now
and the first one for the minimalist
podcast though yeah the first one for
the minimalist uh but yeah we had you at
a live event we did your podcast but um
yeah man uh it's so easy to talk to you
so yeah thanks for being here it's great
i couldn't be happier we're gonna dive
into your book the story of you we're
also going to really dissect the
personalities of all nine people in here
see who we vote off the island today
we'll do that on the maximum but first
this is a listener driven show our first
question today is from facebook ingay
has a question for us how do you start
rewriting your story when you feel
overwhelmed and insecure about who you
are and who you want to be
yeah that's a great question
well first of all you have to look at
the story you find yourself in now right
the story that you have occupied
probably since childhood because all of
us
in childhood craft a narrative
to make sense of who we are uh to make
sense of how we think the world works
and to create a coherent sense of self
right uh and what's happening to you
trauma all the experiences right
and we craft this narrative and then we
unfortunately we drag it into adulthood
with us
without ever stopping to interrogate it
and say is that the story i really want
to live or is that an arcane script that
i'm reading off of and isn't really
serving me anymore like it did in
childhood yeah and so that's the thing
it can serve you for a while but just
because a story or a narrative served
you at some point clinging to that
is often disempowering right oh my gosh
like i
you know this is born out of personal
experience you know as a therapist but
also just as a human being like i grew
up in a crazy well we've had this
conversation yeah right we've had this
conversation oh yeah like i grew up in a
crazy alcoholic drug addicted family i
mean just crazy ass stuff right always
you know chaos
ambulances police cars broken furniture
people falling down the stairs into
christmas are you are you wildly
depressed right now
it sounds like a fast and furious film
yeah exactly it's bringing this sleeve
except only psychological um
and you can imagine the story that i
crafted
to make sense of the world as a little
person so it was like oh well i must be
to blame for all this
yeah or i'm a pest or i'm so different
than all my other friends that have
these wonderful beautiful perfect homes
i mean the list could go on right
there's something wrong with me there's
something missing i wish my father can't
love me because i'm unlovable now that's
just right so i formed that story and it
actually did help me survive because it
made sense of what was happening but i
dragged that into adulthood
and that story no longer served me at
that point it became a very
self-defeating painful self-sabotaging
uh narrative that actually nearly killed
me and what did it do to you
specifically how did it manifest well it
led very easily into a life of drug
addiction and alcoholism right right i
mean just to anesthetize the pain you
know and i could give you a long host
list of you know probably other reasons
right even identifying with my dad
right like to me that in a way in a
weird kind of twisted way it was like a
point of connection with him that i
shared that experience you know after
his death so
all i'm saying is is that i became a a
prisoner of a story i didn't know i was
in
until i had a sponsor i was in my late
20s and one day he was a jungian analyst
an episcopal priest really spiritual
wonderful dude and he said to me one
time
do you ever wonder if you're living in
the wrong story
and you know those kinds of questions
that like you go whoa like back on your
heels and i was like i hope so
you know what i mean like
and he says well you know you don't have
to stay in it um
and so to answer ingest question head on
[Laughter]
how do you start rewriting the story and
so maybe actually i think you did answer
it is understanding that you don't have
to be in this story yes so we begin by
doing what the author you mo willems you
all know mo willems the the author he
says great quote he says if you find
yourself living in the wrong story leave
yeah
so that's kind of like got to figure out
what the story is so i i actually use an
acronym which i don't like acronyms
because they're kind of platitudinal but
being in a 12-step program i also know
they can kind of save your ass sometimes
you know so
first thing is just to see the story
then you gotta own the story right
that's oh
and uh the owning part is like what has
this story done to my life
what has it cost me what has it cost
others
that i've been living in this
false
taken for granted story my whole life
then the next one is to just awaken i
love awakening you know it's like just
realizing okay well what triggers me
into this story right what launches the
story day after day day after day
and then finally is the rewrite
portion right which is
how do i want to create a story that
would accommodate my authentic self that
would align with my values
that would be reflective of the person
my 80 year old self would be proud of
yeah that's so sore
soar right i love it but you know you
got to hang a house i like acronyms yeah
okay oh man you know the only thing i
might add to that is uh you know the
whole
act as if thing right
it's kind of overused and i think it's
used wrong in a lot of ways however i
know when i was changing my story
it was waking up and asking myself what
would a sober ryan do yes what would a
minimalist ryan do what would a healthy
ryan do and you know i acted as if until
eventually you form a new story yes you
you become a different person you have
different behaviors but there is a
little bit of uh
maybe it's not fake until you make it
because it was very genuine actions but
but act as if i think for me really
helped change my story
absolutely it's like when you go to the
fridge and you're used to eating like me
like a sirly orange cake or something
but
you ask yourself instead what would a
healthy person eat right now yeah right
it's to to cast yourself as a new as a
new role oh
yeah right
not the victim not the martyr right
because you know how many of us go
through life
cast and we self-casted roles
that really
aren't the people you want to be yeah
and the victim thing is fascinating
because
we often blame others for whatever
situation we've put ourselves in and
we've put ourselves in that that
situation often because of these stories
that we've
not only told ourselves we've
constructed them and we've clung to them
yes well after their sort of expiration
date yes and you know this is really
important because what's easy to do is
you go through the process of
identifying the story you actually want
to live in it's really easy to shame
yourself for having adopted it which is
the you have to do this with what i love
a children she has this great line she
calls it unconditional self-friendship
to do it with like real self-compassion
and say you know what
this is how i made sense of the world
and actually i need to thank that old
story as negative as it might be
and say goodbye i think that's part of
the journey of rewriting it's like
thanking the old story for what it how
it helped us
and then saying and then parting ways
yeah now that that's huge for me like i
just
you know start to get a little
resentment when i think about my crazy
childhood and things i've done but
i realized like man i had all those
things had to happen for me to be
right here and
i really like myself so yeah accepting
that story is uh
yeah that's huge let's move on to our
callers if you have a question or
comment for our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
podcast john it looks like we have a
question here from jonathan in woodstock
georgia i lost my wife and best friend
of 20 years around christmas time to
cancer and
literally overnight uh lost my identity
of husband then spent the
last year really taking care of my three
girls and decided to step away from work
so i lost my work identity which i've
had for 25 years
speak to
what to do when you've lost major
identities as a man
when it comes to like i'm no longer a
husband but also i'm not a worker and
haven't been for the last year how do
you begin to reshape or step back into
those identities when you've walked away
from them so ian
i don't even know where to start with
jonathan's question other than to say
man i'm really sorry like what a
what a difficult time that you're going
through
and it's true that we get our identities
tied up in being a husband or being a
worker or
in fact it's the first thing we ask
someone we meet them what do you do
and then we recite what's on our
business card as if that's who i am
as a person
and so
where does jonathan even start
yeah i mean there's a sort of a
as i was listening to it the first thing
that came to mind is is that
i don't think those are identities as
much as they are socially assigned roles
and a role in an identity are two
different things let's talk about that
well you i have an identity as a husband
as a father uh as a therapist
uh as an aspiring buddhist as you know
what i mean like i can just go on and on
and on about roles that i've either
adopted or society has assigned to me or
my family assigned to me like in my
family you know i you could say when
some people in families play the role of
the clown other
saying like we have roles
and roles are actually easier to work
with right and to
redefine you could say i'm a
stay-at-home dad that's a role that's
different than i'm a guy who works out
in the world right right he's like you
can play with roles but identity is
something very different i think it has
to do with
your core truth the core of your person
and i think part of the journey towards
psychological and spiritual health and i
interplay those two terms a lot
is really to recover
your own personal wholeness and you know
in in or to not recover it but to
recover your
contact
with the your already existing beauty
and wholeness that's completely separate
from your roles right and that's why
people tend to
misidentify who they are with roles
because they haven't done the work of
saying who am i apart from those roles i
am a beautiful whole
human being that is in the journey
toward awakening more and more to that
core truth about who i am and so for our
friend here i'd say you know just
understand that those are not who you
are those are roles and that's really
good news
really good news and also in trauma
we have an opportunity depending on the
severity of trauma and how we how much
resilience we have
we have the opportunity to awaken
it's painful but we can awaken to the
truth and of the beauty of what we are
and who we are
yeah that is beautiful so do you think a
good place for jonathan to start would
be
with something like the enneagram
because that
to me it's it's uh
what helps you identify kind of these
core tenets of uh right where you lean
towards with preferences and what
fulfills you because like when i hear
him say husband father and worker
what i hear is someone who likes to
contribute
and you know he could kind of find a
common theme with these things like
contribution and be like oh that's
really
you know kind of who i am as a person
but maybe something like the enneagram
could help him even get more clear yeah
he could totally do that except just
remember the enneagram doesn't tell you
who you are it's not it doesn't label an
identity
as much as it is talking to you about
your personality which is different from
identity okay your personality is really
i like to say that you know a very basic
sort of winsome way of defining
personality would be
how you show up for life
that's it okay how you predictably and
habitually act think and feel on a
moment-to-moment basis
every day
right and that's how people know you and
experience you and it's how you
experience yourself
right yeah so it's a great data point
for someone like our friend who just
called in right it's it's it's like one
piece of information that you could bake
into your overall spiritual journey of
figuring out who you are but your
personality is not all of who you are
it's just part of who you are
and sometimes it distracts you from who
you really are
expand on that well i mean you're a
three on the enneagram right you're a
doer right you're called the performer
or the achiever you're a guy who just
crushes it in life i just watched you in
the midst of a crisis
take on a very assertive stance while
the two withdrawing types
do you know what i'm saying and you're
like down to business man for the folks
listening at home we were doing a
patreon live stream at the beginning of
this and uh for whatever reason one of
the microphones was not picking up
and uh so there was a yeah a technical
difficulty and and so i'm much more
tightly wound than you or ryan yeah now
brian's tightly aligned in a different
way
but i would say that you you are very
task focused let's get this right let's
get it done right now
you if you were not very self-aware
three you would be like how does this
reflect on me that this stuff is going
south right now yeah i don't like the
fact that i'm looking bad in this moment
i see that creeping up though because
it's just like well hey i want things to
be
right and smooth and when they're not it
definitely reflects on me in some way
right
as if that matters at all i can step
back and realize well that doesn't
actually matter that's self-awareness
and so what is the
what is the role of self-awareness
in personality and in identity well
you've all met we've all met people who
don't have much self-awareness at a
cocktail party haven't we
and you're like yeah we call them
extroverts
sometimes but you know what i mean it's
like so maybe i would define it's a very
complicated
i could give a long-winded answer but
here's a short one it's the capacity to
monitor
and self-regulate
the way that you act think and feel in
the moment and noticing how does who i
am affect the person that i'm with right
now
how are they responding and i'm able to
kind of you know so
you're an eight on the enneagram right
and he's pointing at danny danny unknown
all right so eights are called the
challengers you are
very assertive
very blunt
sometimes aggressive and domineering
right
some people you have you ever had
someone say to you are you what are you
mad about and you're like i'm not mad
how about if someone if someone has ever
said to you you're kind of intimidating
yeah okay so
in the moment if you have self-awareness
you're with somebody and you can
actually pick up on the cues this person
is being overwhelmed by me right now
and you just holster your guns
and you say i need to adopt a more
loving open vulnerable position right
now that's self-awareness
in service to moving through the world
in a wiser more emotionally attuned way
that's fast that's as fast as i can get
it
we'll we'll dive deeper into danny
specifically because you actually open
your book the new book yeah review with
eight so it actually starts out of order
my mother yeah so we do eights then we
do nines and we start back at the the
ones we have we have someone from every
every persuasion here
one through nine we're gonna we're gonna
dive deep on the maximal episode but
getting back to john here for a second
there's been a trauma that has happened
identifying your personality might be a
tool
to help you uncouple from that identity
clutter yes and in fact we're calling
this episode identity clutter because
quite often are a lot you know we're the
minimalist we talk about clutter and
decluttering all this stuff but really
minimalism is the trojan horse it starts
with the stuff but we have all this
other clutter in our lives and that's
why i thought it was so important today
to talk about identity clutter because
the stories we tell ourselves about who
we are
are one of the most detrimental things
that can be far worse than the excess
material possessions in your home and
quite often we start dealing with that
excess stuff
we are able to look inside and say oh
what kind of
psychological spiritual emotional
clutter is going on in here
what am i telling myself about who i am
so jonathan's at a point right now where
he needs a new story
in his life because that old story even
if it did serve him i would question as
to whether or not it did how empowering
it actually was but even now it's i'm so
sorry that you lost your wife that's
yeah i can't even imagine um yeah
in fact i i get a little teary just
thinking about it right because
uh
and then the whole life changing
but sometimes
you have this cascade of events for me
my mom died my marriage ended both in
the
the same month
and then my job ended shortly after that
you start re-prioritizing you start
telling a different story um yeah yeah
you absolutely do and actually
crisis
is the opportunity to and actually will
force you
to rewrite the story and i think part of
what the what i hope the story of you
does is it kind of communicate
communicates to people
you actually can do it before you hit a
crisis
in fact you might actually avoid a
crisis in your life yeah if you
proactively
work on the story you've been telling
yourself and others about who you are
and how you think the world works you
don't need to get into a car crash in
order to know you need to wear a seat
belt you can put the seat belt on right
now and maybe avoid the actual pain of
of the car or you don't need to wait for
a car crash to drive more quote
responsibly right right sometimes
it takes the recklessness and then the
crash in order to change one's behavior
if one survives through that but what
you're saying is you don't necessarily
have to go through the crash in order to
change your behavior no but oftentimes
you'll start to feel the symptoms you
know
like like you just feel like uh
not at home in your own world
it's like the feeling of dis-ease right
the feeling of or it might be why have i
been married three times why have i lost
the same job four times why you know
what i mean or whatever it is you start
to self reflect and think question
interrogate i love the word
the assumptions
the underlying premise of the story and
and to be able to exhume the story from
the past and say
how can i rewrite that into a brighter
better truer future
right in present moment i just i get so
excited i was with a guy recently and i
i actually asked him to title
his story
and he had you know given a long you
know story previously to me about how he
grew up blah blah blah and he said a
second-hand boy
because he had grown up in poverty and
he had to buy all of his clothes in a
consignment shop but all of his friends
had money yeah and he just carried this
weight of i'm the second-hand boy and i
said well are you still living that
story he's like yeah and i'm like how is
it serving you he goes i'm tortured
and i'm like
you know you don't have to stay in that
story and he looked at me like i
invented
do you fire what i'm saying you looked
at me like i don't
because it's like you mean i'm not a
victim of previous circumstances that
i'm stuck with it's like no
actually
you can't deny the facts of what
happened
but you can rewrite your relationship to
it
and begin like you were saying i like
myself well you know the alternative
story that you could have crafted
right based on your personal history
holy smokes could have been way
different and you actually did have to
have crisis yeah yeah i did have to have
that car crash
i'll tell you there's uh there's a story
i hold on to right now
that every time i tell it to myself i
have to interrupt it and that's the
story of
um when everything's going really well
yes i'm like
it's about to hit the fan yes and it's
gonna get the rug's gonna get pulled out
from underneath of me because growing up
there was this constant
you know christmas is supposed to be a
happy time well mom's getting a dui so
now christmas is ruined and so forth and
so on yeah so um
i don't know if i've been able to
stop telling myself that story as much
as like recognize right when i get that
feeling of like oh the rug's going to be
ripped out from underneath of me i can
kind of interrupt it and say hey you
don't have to feel this way yeah it's
probably not going to be ripped out from
underneath of you but um but i but yeah
that's a story that i constantly have to
kind of interrupt so i would call that a
taken for granted internalized belief
that you
understandably took on board as a little
person and it is one belief in a larger
narrative
right like your narrative is filled with
all kinds
of
negative
uh
self-defining beliefs
right
and again to to be aware of it
to compassionately talk to the voice
like when i get a voice like i have the
same one right like it's it's like first
of all it's a little trauma based
right which means that it's grooved even
deeper down man like that thing's rooted
yeah right yeah and it's very
self-protective i don't want to be
disappointed i don't want to be hurt i
want to be ready in case when the you
know what hits the fan yeah because it
always hits the fan right right right
and it's like to be able to actually
even look at that part of you and say
what do you need right now
how can i help you
yeah i know that you're well intentioned
you're you're trying to help me right
now but
that's an old story and i'd like to live
in a different story about hope
not naive because bad stuff could happen
on christmas yeah but guess what i'll be
okay because i was okay the last time
yeah i made it out i like that and
that's a yeah that's helpful
i love uh having my own personal therapy
sessions
hey jonathan i'm going to send you two
things one is a copy of the story of you
if you want to dive deeper and by the
way we did a live event with ian in
dallas we have a recording that's going
to come out soon on our patreon page for
any of the patreon supporters but
jonathan i'm going to send you
a a link to that as soon as it is
available because we dive deep into our
own personalities our own trauma and
also a lot of the audience trauma and
what i've found is sometimes when
someone's asking a question about their
own trauma their own identity it holds
up a mirror yes for each of us yes and
so we did a great event with him
back in in dallas and so we'll send you
a link to that by the way we're getting
ready to go out on the road again
starting next week it's called the love
people use things tour 20 cities in
total we have 11 left we'll be in new
york which i think i think is sold out
but we'll be in boston and dc and
toronto and columbus and minneapolis and
chicago and
vancouver and seattle
san francisco los angeles i think that's
11. somewhere around there the
minimalists.com tour if you want to grab
your tickets
alabama do we have any comments from the
patreon live stream we'll get to their
questions during the maximal episode we
actually do have a comment in regards to
the dallas show brianna says that she
saw ian at the dallas show and it was a
blast it was awesome it was one of my
favorite events yeah um mine two of the
year was best that's awesome that was
gonna say i think that's like the
biggest laugh that i've gotten which
might say something about me being a
seven and feeling reward when i make
people laugh but uh but yeah that was
like the biggest laugh i think we got
the biggest part is what reveals the
seven right
did you see where his attention
immediately migrated was the biggest
laugh the most fun i had you know on
that show was this moment you know what
i'd like to you you were telling me how
i'm tightly wound in a different way um
can you maybe just give me a brief
summary of kind of what you were
speaking towards well you actually
hinted at it when you were speaking
earlier about that sort of trauma voice
right that is a part of
uh the story it isn't the big
overarching story but it's a piece of it
yeah
i would say um that you're anxious oh
yeah and that anxiety can come out in a
very sunny optimistic way
as kind of a cover
for the anxiety and also a way to
release the anxiety mm-hmm uh so there's
a kind of when when a seven is kind of
on autopilot there's a kind of maniky
kind of quality to it even though you
don't have the right you know but i know
what you're i can get there yeah you
don't go all robin williams right you
know what i mean but you does that make
sense it does it does make sense yeah
yeah that's a great observation all
right ryan what time is it you know time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments too
two 937-202-4 six five four yes indeed
now ian during the lightning round this
is where ryan and i and our guest we do
our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we call them minimal maximum we
did this on the live show yeah yes yes
indeed and so we call the minimum
maximums podcast sean makes them pretty
he puts a some sort of wrapping paper on
them he throws them in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if they'd like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place thanks to our good
friend jessica lynn williams she is our
resident oh she's a uh she's a seven or
a two i don't i think oh i don't know i
think she's a seven she's going to go
with seven i could see your venus yeah
anyway um she handles our social media
she's wonderful minimalmaxims.com is
where you find all of our minimal maxims
now and you'll probably remember we
usually just monitor on a bit until we
get something that's relatively pithy
but mike has a question for us how do i
get past the story that i'm not good
enough and find peace with who i am
um
here's some of the pithy for you and
maybe we can we can
unpack it a bit
enough is enough
when you decide it's enough
i mean i usually talk about that with
respect to stuff because we're always
looking for more more more well why is
that because i feel incomplete
in a way and consumerism is merely the
ideology that buying something is going
to make me happy or it's going to make
me complete or ideally both as soon as
i'm complete then of course i'll be
happy i'll be fulfilled i'll be
everything i ever imagined and it's just
one consumer purchase away
right but of course that bleeds over
into every other area of life i'm not
enough with respect to my job i'm not
enough
with respect to my family i'm not enough
with respect to being a father or a
mother i'm not enough as a son
and that story we tell ourselves is so
well you'll never be enough
if that's the story that i tell myself
right mm-hmm
yeah absolutely
me or you baby you go for it well i mean
all right so what i think what our
friend is talking about actually is
shame
and uh shame is something all of us
carry to different degrees you
definitely don't want to be shameless in
this life that's what otherwise you'd be
pulling your pants down to church all
the time you know what i'm saying like
that shame has a positive thing to it
right
but shame is the sense that not that you
know guilt would be uh i've done
something wrong and shame is the sense
that i am something wrong
and that's what leads to those kinds of
feelings
and guess what in my own life you know
i've been around a little bit i've been
around a minute and i just realized
guess what it's part of the human
condition
it's just you know it's programmed
material there's no way out however you
can live in a different you can regard
those voices differently yeah
right you and that's where buddhism has
really helped me right the ability to
stand back and observe when those voices
and feelings start to emerge
and learn how to be with them yeah until
they're ready to let go and to and and
really to parent them
you know parent yeah your parent the the
feelings that you're experiencing parent
parent the experience yeah yeah of what
you're experiencing it reminds me um
i was talking to this like trauma
specialist and
uh i i asked him like how to deal with a
lot of the anxiety and trauma that comes
up and he gave me similar advice but it
was really about like
you know when you think about the stuff
that happened when you were a kid like
talk to that little kid yes and really
what he's saying is is like parent right
that anxiety and like what did that kid
need to hear right yeah and when
reflexively our tendency is to beat the
kid up and tell him to stop yeah which
only makes the kid louder
yeah yeah right it just the kid just
starts yelling louder and starts you
know what i mean it's like they go into
fireman mode
right um
well my pithy answer is this
we accept ourselves as soon as our
actions align with our values
so
i say this because
when your
actions align with your values there's
not a lot of shame and guilt involved
and and i learned this uh like back when
we started
the the minimalists i got clear on what
my values were
like here's the things that i know make
me tick here are the things that
uh make me feel like i'm living a good
life but when i looked at my actions
they were not in alignment
with those values so i think i think
that is the first step and you said
something about the human condition and
i do think that like there's always
and yeah i don't know someone might
disagree with me but
there's always a little bit of
this void that like we're always kind of
searching to
be whole to be complete
and i think we can narrow that void a
little bit by
our actions aligning with our values
but i think it is part of the human
condition to always feel like there's a
little bit more that we can do and maybe
there is a little bit more we can do but
i don't think
you know i don't think it's uh
there are some you know um
mystics who probably transcend that
but i think by and large you know people
will wake up every morning at the back
okay what can i do today to like be a
more whole person and that's okay yeah
yeah i like i like what ryan's saying
here ian because a couple things here
with with his pithy answer so we accept
ourselves as soon as our actions align
with our values we have two options here
you can change your actions or you can
also change what you value quite often
we're valuing all the things that
society has thrust on to us oh i'm
supposed to value this i'm supposed to
do this i'm supposed to be this type of
person i'm supposed to be the director
of operations at this company that that
way i'm significant and i will feel the
shame
that i've created in my own life if i
don't achieve what everyone else is
telling me i'm supposed to achieve the
problem with that is quite often we
achieve those things and then we don't
feel the fulfillment exactly we actually
feel the opposite right yes yeah and so
ryan's also bringing up this idea of the
void talk about another disempowering
story
when ryan i lived in montana for five
years you don't go there and say look at
all this void you say wow look at all
this wide open space
this isn't a void this is just wide open
space so so when you go to a museum
you're not saying oh this room is
such a void wow this is beautiful it's
stunning and it all has to do with the
story that we've told ourselves that
maybe it's not a void maybe it's just
wide open space that's open for
opportunity yeah i love it yeah by the
way i don't know if you can edit this or
not but i'm going to say it
after reading your book
i thought multiple times
and maybe you're already going to do it
which just actually validates my
brilliance
which is
you need to lead retreats on it wow like
you should go get a beautiful center
and invite 100 people to come
and lead them through aligning of values
and you know all these different steps
that you have in the book
and uh it could be like an amazing
boutique experience for people they have
access to you to have time and actually
to move them through the book all the
exercises i just think it would slam yes
in fact i want my free ride right now
where's my comp i want my comp all right
we'll do it in nashville that's right in
fact this is a perfect segue it's almost
like i gave him five dollars to talk
about this
for our right here right now segment we
talk about one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist we did sort
of a it was an online retreat version of
this this is during the the pandemic
before we we could tour
we did uh this series called
relationship with les where we talked
about some of the themes of the book
because
what i've identified is that it's rarely
about pursuing more it's rarely about
getting more you're already enough and
that enough is usually uncovered by
subtracting yes so we did this five part
series you can find it over on patreon
right now all five parts are now
published patreon.com the minimalist
it's called relationship with less we
got a bunch more to talk about but first
malaban what do you got for us here are
some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners hi josh and ryan my
name is sandra and i'm from norway i
would like to share a quote that changed
my view on minimalism i've been on this
journey for about seven years now and
this month i have been doing my version
on the minimalism game where i try to
let go of 500 items in total my
boyfriend saw a pair of shoes i was
going to sell and said that they were
nice shoes i told them i agreed but that
i did not wear them and that they did
not add value to my life anymore he then
said this
just because something is pretty doesn't
mean you have to own it
hey ryan and josh this is muriel from
grand haven michigan i just listened to
episode 210 about student debt i have a
tip related to that topic i wanted to
share
i'm currently a senior at grand valley
state university and i'll be graduating
this may with no student debt
i've put in a lot of work in many ways
to get to this point but my number one
recommendation for people looking to
avoid student debt is to apply for
scholarships specific to who you are
for example i'm studying natural
resources management so i applied to
many scholarships related to my field of
study
you can find scholarships based on your
interests academic performance special
talents your major and many other things
i even got a one thousand dollar
scholarship from my credit union
there are scholarships for everything
you just have to intentionally search
out the ones you have the best chance of
getting
they may take a long time to apply for
but it's worth the time you put in if
they help you stay out of debt
additionally check to see if your
university has a list of available
scholarships
gvsu has a website called my
scholarships where you can create a
profile and they suggest scholarships
specific to you and you can apply for
them directly through the website
you can also search for specific
scholarships there
this is what i found to work for me and
i hope some of your listeners find this
helpful all right y'all big thanks to
our guest ian morgan kron for joining us
today he'll be with us this week on the
maximal episode as well check out his
new book it's called the story of you
i'll hold it up uh for our youtube
viewership but also you can check out
his wonderful podcast including the
interview that we did with him the
quickest i've ever seen ryan cry on a
podcast
hey i held back i choked up
all right i cried a little it was like
30 seconds in he was crying
like a little baby
a beautiful beautiful baby
you're so nice best friend a baby that
was having lots of fun
you could check his podcast called
typology also ian kron if you want to
follow him on social media we'll put a
link to all of that including the book
the podcast everything in the show notes
by the way ian we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
are tin signs that you're living in a
broken story what if you're in your 30s
40s 50s or even 60s and you still don't
know who you are in fact this one came
up quite a bit
and how do you reinvent yourself and
rewrite your story after a traumatic
breakup plus a million more questions
for ian kron and the minimalists and if
you want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalists to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
gain immediate access to hundreds of
hours of private archives recordings of
live events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at theminimalists.com
on behalf of ian morgan kron ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant who is not here today but
she's our other three we also have alex
and bex and mariah here today but
they're going to be joining us on the
maximal as well my name is joshua fields
milburn reminding you to love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it